-We're here with Tina Fey,
and we were talking
about Restless Leg --
the Restless Leg Tour.
You are doing the Beacon Theatre
here in New York City
with our friend Amy Poehler.
There's the art for
Restless Leg.
-That's Amy.
And do you guys still --
Do people still
accidentally call you Amy?
-Uh...yeah.
-Okay.
But the Beacon is a beautiful
theater here in New York City.
You're going
to do a lot of shows.
You're doing a show
on Super Bowl Sunday.
-Yes. You pointed
that out to me,
which I thought was so funny.
So, we are doing --
We're coming to New York.
We're sitting down for,
I want to say, 11 nights.
-Which is fantastic.
We may be -- We may actually be
setting some kind of record
for most consecutive nights
of a comedy tour
at the Beacon
by two white women.
-Wow! That's pretty.
-They're gonna put all that
on a plaque.
-You and Amy, I would imagine,
as collaborators --
I'm familiar with
how well you work together,
but there are still things
you vehemently disagree on.
-Well, there are very
few things we disagree on.
Like, people, in fact --
People often ask us --
We do a Q&A
sometimes in our show,
and a question
we always get asked is,
"What do you guys fight about?
What do you two fight about?"
And it's kind of
a sexist question, right?
Like, "What do you guys
fight about?"
And we really don't fight.
And there's very few things
that we disagree about,
and one of them,
we've discovered,
is that Amy hates Halloween
and I love Halloween.
-I'm shocked.
-Yeah.
She's, like -- She doesn't
like the aesthetic of it.
-I'm shocked you like it.
-Well, yeah, I don't --
I like corny-mom
HomeGoods Halloween.
-Got it.
-Like, basic-bitch Halloween.
-Okay. Oh, I see.
Not like -- You don't
want to actually scare anyone.
-No, I don't want
anything scary to happen.
I want, like -- I have little,
like, light-up boxes that say
like, "A witch lives here
with her two little monsters."
And Amy's like, "Boo!"
And, so, you know, there have
been times where I'll send her,
like, stuff that
I have in my house,
and she's like, "I hate that.
Get it out of your house."
So what I thought
I could maybe do here is,
I would like to show you
some of the things that I own,
and then you tell me
if I'm crazy,
because she says,
like, you know --
Because here's what I got.
I have like, you know --
I have like two or three --
I know it's three --
full-sized skeletons.
-Three full-size skeletons.
-I have a fake TV
that looks like a '50s TV
that when you turn it on, like,
a hand comes through the screen.
-Yeah.
-I have my whole family.
I have 3-D portraits
of every member of my family
from the Haunted Mansion
in Disney World,
which is cool,
because if you look at it,
like, from one side,
it's your face,
but if you look at it
from the other side,
it's the face of a person
who wasted $200.
[ Laughter ]
So, she judges me
for these things.
But I want to show you -- Okay.
-Is this the first one
you want to show?
-Yeah. Okay.
So, let me take you
through these.
Okay, so, this is the first
thing. This is simple.
This is a very simple mug
with pumpkins on it
that says "Scary!"
-Yeah.
-Just know that if my house
was on fire
and I had to choose
between my wedding album
and this mug,
I would 100% take this mug.
-Got it.
-When I saw
this mug in a HomeGoods,
I felt like must be what
like Leonardo DiCaprio
feels like when he sees
a 19-year-old model.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You had to have it.
-Because I was like,
"God damn it!
I will have her."
-Is this a Halloween-only mug?
-No. This is -- You know why?
Because it doesn't actually
say anything about Halloween,
so it's it's year round.
It's year round.
And I like it,
because if I were an object,
I would be this mug,
because it says "Scary!",
but it's not really scary
and it's a little bit wider
and heavier than you expect.
-Okay.
-Okay, so, let me see.
So, I'm normal, right?
That's not a weird thing to own?
-No, that's not a weird thing.
-That's fine. I'm fine.
Okay, okay.
-Things are
about to change as far as --
-Okay, because then last year,
I bought this guy.
-Okay. Let's take a look.
-Okay.
Now, he is a
nicely dressed scarecrow.
There's nothing alarming --
inherently alarming about him.
You know, he's maybe
not something a woman purchases
while her husband is alive.
-Yeah.
-Feels more like
something that should be made
for you
by volunteers from the church.
But I bought him. Am I okay?
-Um, okay.
-It's starting to turn. Okay.
-It's starting to turn.
-Well --
-Now, this seems -- Can we --
-Yeah, so, this -- Okay,
if you're getting concerned,
things are gonna get worse for
you, because then I went back to
the same store
and I bought these two.
-Yeah, definitely --
definitely the same craftsman.
-Yeah, and I love them.
And, listen,
I had to buy both of them,
because, obviously,
they're a couple.
-Yeah.
-Right? And he's
a pumpkin football man,
and she's a cheerleader
and she's wearing a ring
around her neck,
so they have clearly made
some sort of chastity promise
to each other.
And, yes, I have used
the football in his hands
to keep him out
until Thanksgiving.
-Did -- Was this one free,
and then these were each
like $10,000 each?
Like, it was like a drug dealer?
-It was like a pyramid scheme.
Yes.
-Okay, now things have turned
for the worse.
-Now even I have to admit
this is problematic.
Okay, so, I went back to
the same store
and then I bought this guy.
Why did I buy him?
-Yeah.
-He looks like
a Victorian child pallbearer,
but he's clearly
a middle-aged gourd.
He has a ring of human hair
that is realistic
and we can only assume
is the hair of his victims.
-Yeah.
-He is the size of
a humidifier and he costs $60.
-Can I also say one other
problem I have with him?
He has such worse posture.
-Yeah.
No, even he is sad
that he exists.
So, this is the final question.
Is Amy right
and I'm crazy or am I okay?
-I think --
Do you want me to say?
-Yeah.
-I think you're okay.
-Oh, okay!
I think you guys know I'm crazy.
-Also, before you go,
very exciting.
Girls5eva,
which is a fantastic show...
-Thank you so much.
-...has a third season
coming out on Netflix,
and you can also watch the first
two seasons on Netflix.
-Yes. I believe mid-March,
all three seasons
come out on Netflix.
It is a great show --
-With a fantastic cast.
-Yeah. Great Meredith Scardino
wrote it.
Sara Bareilles,
Renée Goldsberry,
Busy Philipps,
and the great Paula Pell.
-There you go.
You can't go wrong.
You guys, that's Tina Fey.
"Mean Girls"
in theaters tomorrow.
For info on
the Restless Leg Tour,
go to tinaamytour.com.
We'll be right back
with Andrew Scott.